moi j'aime des vieux culottes qui
flottent comme dans la rue tu sais je
trouve ça très joli
alors les jeans j'aime bien quand ça
ça dégage un peu ça tombe un peu
tu es plus mignon il est bon on était il
est bon en hiver
[Musique]
c'est une tissu géniale parce que tout
neuf ou très très pâle il est toujours
joli comme je vous fais de la casquette
vous faites comme ça vous avez une paire
de pantalon normale tandis que ça c'est
formidable moi je sais que je suis
toujours sale je vis toujours ça je fais
rien aujourd'hui par exemple ce vieil
père qui va bien tout et là je les
connais ça j'ai déjà fait le ménage j'ai
fait des parquets
promener avec le bébé et je vais sortir
ce soir et je vais pas me changer
je veux pas pourquoi